whether it's at my restaurants or at
home I think food should always stand up
and be noticed it doesn't matter if a
dish is light and delicate or full-on
and Gutsy the flavors should be distinct
and clear and that means always getting
the maximum taste from your ingredients
today it's all about vibrant muscular
food so fasten your seatbelt for my
ultimate breakfast lunch and dinner
packed with big and bold flavors first
up a Punchy breakfast of mergers and
Fontina stuffed croissants
flavor there it's incredible for lunch a
spicy Mexican soup be adventurous but
beware
serve with quick tortilla chips and a
pic of the guy or dip Maggie for dinner
I'll be setting the world to write with
my eldest Megan
I'm so annoyed when we make one of our
favorite dishes crispy roast duck with
pancakes and black bean dipping sauce
Cena's is your favorite that you can
make it followed by a spiced banana
tartatan wow
boom these are my ultimate recipes for a
day bursting with their big and bold
breakfast lunch and dinner starting with
a breakfast that can't fail to wake you
up merguez and Fontina stuff croissants
okay big and bold I was living in France
I stayed there for three years once
twice a week I treated myself to the
most amazing
bold breakfast and it started off with
these Beauties here mergys cheap but
incredibly tasty
start off with a nice hot pan mergers in
it's a very spicy sausage doesn't need
any help doesn't need any chili Just a
Touch of salt and pepper
you can smell the spice they're starting
to release all that wonderful oil that
flavor in there
add a couple of cloves I'll finely
sliced garlic
spread the garlic across the pan it
instantly changes color takes on this
nice dark Rich golden color
now take a look with the heat out for
the parsley
the stalks of soft herbs like parsley
and coriander can be used to impart
flavor during cooking but the leaves
should always be added just before
serving to give maximum color and
fragrance
[Music]
and then finish that off with my capers
amazing
now take your quest on
they're literally 24 hours old so
they're crispy on the outside and just
slice off
the lid
this recipe is a great way to use up any
leftover croissants from the day before
I used to cringe when I saw the French
Cooks throw away croissants I used to
cry thinking oh my God
any idea what he's throwing away in
terms of flavor whatever you do do not
wipe out that pan dunk your croissants
mopping up all that amazing flavor and
caramelizing the inside
for that beautiful don't forget the lids
and then get your thumbs and go inside
the croissant
all I want to do now is create a little
pocket
and just manipulate the croissant now
this is where it gets exciting
mix up the Capers the garlic the
sausages look at the color of that
wonderful delicious flavored oil now
some cheese but not just any cheese
Fontina cheese is like the number one
cheese for grilling and because it's a
very rich cheese you shave it thinner
than you would a white truffle but it
gives a really nice saltiness and a
light Smoky flavor
Touch of Pepper
with salt
place these big boys on the tray
literally 30 seconds
on the grill
here we go
nice
crisp
packs full of Flavor now top them
and that for me
it's almost like being back in Paris
except this time I don't have to share
them with the French
My ultimate big and bold breakfast
mergers and Fontina stuff croissants a
great way to start the day
[Music]
never be scared of trying new flavors in
your cooking
a few key ingredients can make all the
difference here's a closer look at some
I'll be using later
peppercorns may be small but whatever
the color in terms of flavor they're one
of the heavy weights of the kitchen
with the exception of the pink type all
peppercorns are fruits from the same
flowering Vine
it's the stage at which they are
harvested and how they are processed
that determines their unique colors and
taste
today I'll be using the fiery black and
perfume Pink types to add a big bold
punch to my pudding
[Music]
for dinner I'll be cooking duck hugely
popular in Chinese cuisine this bird may
be less meaty than a chicken but it's
intense rich flavor means the meat goes
a long long way
[Music]
wild or farmed duck meat is packed with
protein vitamins and essential nutrients
and I'm going to slow roast one in my
dinner dish of crispy roast duck with
pancakes
chillies are a fabulous ingredient and
one of my absolute favorites is the
Chipotle
Chipotles begin life as a green jalapeno
pepper the process of drying and smoking
lends an intense Smoky flavor to balance
their spicy heat
dried Chipotles can be brought as a
paste powder or whole which is how I'll
be using them in my big bold lunch
Chili's come in all shapes and sizes and
heat and are used throughout the world
but if there's one Cuisine has really
turned cooking them into an art form
it's Mexican they're experts at building
layer upon layer flavored with delicious
chilies and spices so for my ultimate
big and bold lunch spicy Mexican soup
it's hearty delicious robust but served
with some tortillas and a wonderful
salsa it's almost like a complete meal
in one starting with some finely chopped
red onions for my soup let's get some
heat going early these are chipotle so
they're Smoky Rich they don't come with
any warning signal and these are
seriously hot so be adventurous but
beware
a nice teaspoon of toasted cumin oregano
dried
now it's not frying off spices the Heat
you'll see the chilies start swelling up
delicious garlic
be quite generous on the oil because
that helps to blow out the chili right
now those onions and garlic are on fire
we're going to balance the sort of heat
from the Chipotle with sugar
turn up the heat and really start
caramelizing that sugar and the chili
gives off the most amazing aroma
next fry for a tablespoon of tomato
puree
add a can of chopped tomatoes
cook kidney beans
and vegetable or chicken stock to cover
there's something quite exciting about
big and bold flavors because in the
restaurants you have to be somewhat
controlled you can't go crazy so so
cooking these kind of dishes at home
gives me that kind of release chilies
particularly when they're dried continue
to swell and release their heat as
they're cooked so the longer you cook
your dish the hotter it will be
[Music]
but it's not as powerful it needs to be
yet and every five six seven eight
minutes actually gonna get stronger
hotter and more delicious
bring it up to the ball and cook that
out for 15 minutes
whilst I allow the chili heat to infuse
I'm going to crack on with quick crunchy
tortilla chips and a fabulously fresh
and spicy tomato salsa no New Mexico as
pico de gallo
start by finely dicing three ripe
tomatoes
one or two deceded fresh jalapeno
peppers
half a red onion
then chop a good handful of fresh
coriander
add the juice from two limes
salt and pepper
and a drizzle of extra virgin olive oil
for the tortilla chips rub a little
olive oil onto six large shop-bought
wheat wraps
sprinkle with smoked paprika and gently
massage in
cut each wrap into triangles and spread
them onto a baking tray
eat for three to four minutes in a
preheated oven 180 degrees until golden
brown and lead to cool
to complete my Mexican lunch I need to
finish my deliciously fragrant spicy
soup
the spices there it is absolutely spot
on
now for the cooling down process
the Mexicans are brilliant at building
layer upon layer of flavor with
delicious chilies and spices but they're
also experts at tempering their dishes
with cooling ingredients like avocado
sour cream and cheese that's why you can
take that amount of chili you don't have
a spoon of richness spice all of a
sudden avocados almost like a little
fire blanket over those chillies
further count of the chilly heat
Mexicans use a rich Tangy crumbly cheese
but I'm sprinkling on Lancashire which
is a Great British substitute
and last but not least cooling fresh
coriander one delicious spicy Mexican
soup serve that with your tortilla chips
and your pico de gallo salsa
a phenomenal blend of textures and
layers and spice and creaminess big bold
and delicious
one of the secrets to making fantastic
food at home is learning to be confident
when you're using strong flavors all
dishes need to be balanced but don't be
afraid of using herbs and spices to make
your cooking vibrant and exciting here's
my ultimate big and bold dinner a meal
that demands to be taken notice of
[Music]
and helping me in the kitchen is my
eldest daughter Megan
crispy roast up with pancakes
with the addy kick of a black bean
dipping sauce
Megan gonna help with the duck Donnie
your favorite yeah
yeah now how's your boyfriend
right I'm going come on
that woke you up didn't it so what do
you love most about duck video
the dipping sauce and let's get the duck
in the oven first
it's a little bit of salt in there
please
then some pepper thank you
some spring onion garlic and ginger now
why do you think we pour that in there
to season it and flavor it
how come do you put them in whole like
that not smaller it's going inside we're
not using it for sauce or anything so
it's just going to make it really nice
what are they
star a nice sorry
so what happens as the duck roasts on
the outside it creates this really nice
perfume Aroma inside
tuck that in there to get it spicy rub
all that Chinese five spice yeah over
almost like you're massaging
good
make sure you get it all in even the
little wings here underneath there
just like I used to do to you my bath
I used to wash your little handes
I know those days are long gone I know I
know I know it's your dad
that is seriously spicy with the duck
there's generally quite a lot of fat
there yeah so we can put it on this
little bench
okay and that
goes there by slowly roasting it okay
it's gonna get nice and crisp on the
outside all that fat is going to render
inside the breast so therefore it's
going to get all nice and juicy yeah
right ducks in
three and a half hours at 160 degrees
Celsius
your favorite part you said was the
dipping sauce why is it your favorite
part I think it really adds to the dark
it makes it really tasty it's seen as
it's your favorite now you can make it
I'm gonna do nothing okay daddy's gonna
put his feet up so uh first off the
garlic there's one good girl wash your
fingers please always do good
nice
nice oh you're fast
huh what's your fingers I am
wash your fingers slide slow down please
14.
all right that's enough right a little
teaspoon of olive oil
a few years time we'll be teaching how
to drive as well as cook how exciting is
that you and I in a car
scary
okay garlic in
duck is traditionally served with hoisin
sauce but my brood love the additional
big bold punch of black beans nice Megan
and I add soy sauce and lastly for that
classic Chinese sweet and sour element
brown rice vinegar and honey
are you happy with the flavor I'm really
happy
you can taste everything in there
dipping sauce done ducks in the oven
let's start the dessert the most amazing
Tata tan
they are pink peppercorns
they're really good they don't taste
anything
black quite sweet aren't they they're
really sweet very fruity the pink
peppercorns give it the sweetness the
black peppercorns give the heat now
what is that baby
vanilla this is one of the easiest
desserts in the world to make but one of
the most delicious it's a sort of take
on the classic apple or pear to tan but
when you caramelize those bananas with a
peppercorns and the vanilla I bet that
tastes amazing oh my goodness incredible
okay then made the caramel start off
with a coal pen first
and you just press that butter in there
how come do you do it like that and not
let it just melt naturally because I
want the butter to stay cold because I'm
gonna stick the bananas in there okay
and then we'll make the caramel and
caramelize the bananas at the same time
so in goes those vanilla vanilla seeds
pods in there as well okay peppercorn's
done yeah well done good girl sprinkle
them over that butter just naturally
naturally
nice and they're not just very carefully
sprinkle sugar
over that
you're doing them all the same size
roughly the same size
wedge it into the butter well you know
what I want the bananas really
caramelized you just stop them between
if you cram them in like this okay
they'll stop them moving around
nothing's moving nothing is okay so all
wedged in there
let's bring the peppercorns on top of
the banana so you've got that flavor
in the caramel and the top and the
bottom right
puff pastry
puff pastry is difficult and time
consuming to make so I always buy ready
made when I'm at home
to get the best flavor and texture go
for the all butter type and keep your
pastry cold before using it
and this is where it gets really
exciting you get your fingers you just
pinch the end so you thin the end if you
do that for me very carefully you have
to be quick because the heat of your
fingers can melt the pastry how comes
you do it
because we get it nice and thin so we
can clip it underneath
now take a spoon
and what we do is lift up that banana
and tuck it underneath see looks like a
parcel like a parcel and see the thin
bits of pastry yeah how easy it is to
get it underneath yeah and that's why
you thin them out you do it so quickly
or because I have to be quick otherwise
the paste will melt
notice how we're not using anything
sharp so we're not would that cut the
pastry if you that's right
see how locked down that is
[Music]
gas on
start caramelizing that
those three little holes are so
important if we didn't put a hole in the
pastry and it will cause a lot of steam
to the pastry never Cooks it just goes
really soggy okay so really important
the camera's live now we're working the
camel give a little Shake how can you
see the caramel through the pastry look
what happens when it tilts yeah see all
comes running down
see yeah I see now that pastry okay is
like clinging on to the bananas and so
when we turn it upside down we've got
this glove full of these caramelized
bananas
look at that wow
it looks like
[Laughter]
lucky ah look at likey got you now baby
oh it's your birthday soon 15. I've just
worked it out
on my 50th you're 18.
we should do a joint party yeah I love
it
for the old one
old one 12 lunchtime
Megan please we'll go on later perfect
this is what I get excited now look at
the color of that caramel so tilt the
pan again see how dark it is now yeah
it's gotten a lot darker now it didn't
take long didn't take long at all that's
nearly ready for the oven but before I
put that in I'll get the duck out wow
how's the doctor
crispy wow and delicious how crispy that
is it's really crispy that's what
happens when it slow Cooks
so 20 minutes for the duck to rest and
20 minutes in the oven at 190 to 200
degrees for our banana tartar time
to knock up a quick Hoisin and cucumber
salad to put in our crispy duck pancakes
for the dressing combine hoisin sauce
rice wine vinegar
soy sauce
[Music]
a dash of sesame oil
and to give it that zingy Asian punch
some freshly grated root Ginger
[Music]
for the salad trim and cut spring onions
into very fine matchsticks
peel a whole cucumber into long thin
ribbons
and Shred in a couple of baby gem
lettuces
season and toss this fresh crunchy salad
in the sweet yummy Hoisin dressing
combination that never fails to get the
kids eating their greens wow look at
that
so see now where that pastry is
caramelizing caramel so dark and just a
little tip
gas back on and that will release it
because if you tip it and it's still
sticking then some of your bananas
we'll stick yeah so now let's see when
it starts spinning around like that it's
moving around it's moving around and
here we are the Moment of Truth when you
know your daddy
is the best chef in the world ready
wow
the vanilla
how delicious
isn't that really good as well
[Music]
done crispy doing sauce cucumber salad
ready so if you take them and your
dipping sauce put them over thank you
I'll take the duck don't drop it promise
oh
okay
My ultimate big and bold dinner of
crispy roast duck with pancakes with a
Hoisin dress salad and some extra oomph
from Megan's favorite black bean dipping
sauce
[Music]
I think he's a bit more duck in there
honestly it's like a black burrito Mommy
Dad
and for a big and bold pudding delicious
spiced banana tartatan
Jack's gonna be silk can I have a little
bit I think we might have to save him
some swimming makes him very hungry
let's save him a wishbone in the duck
that's me
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
[Music]
today I'm taking my cue from Italy a
country that takes home cooking family
and fresh vibrant flavors extremely
seriously the Italians are brilliantly
using good food to bring people together
as well as being delicious today's
dishes are also really quick and easy to
make leaving you more time to sit down
and enjoy them with your friends and
family first up in my ultimate Italian
food a deliciously tasty breakfast of
fennel sausage frittata
it's light fluffy and it smells
incredible next a lunch to Whiskey away
to Italy in the first fortfall grilled
sardines with gremolata and also pasta
salad fresh clean almost if we sat on
him Alpha Coast
and as boys joined forces as Jack helps
me cook an incredible dinner with dishes
from the length and breadth of Italy
mmm
starter from the south quick fig Jam
crostini with creamy burrata
from the north a hearty slow-cooked beef
cheek Ragu with Papa Deli well when you
cook this for your girlfriend one day
just tell her where you got the recipe
for money promise promise
rounding off with a Tuscan inspired
dessert luxurious espresso panna cotta
with cinnamon hazelnut brittle Maggie
how is it it's so tasty follow these
ultimate recipes and you too can Embrace
breakfast lunch and dinner the
passionate Italian way
starting with breakfast a fennel sausage
frittata
foreign thing about frittata is the fact
there's no set recipe because it's
basically eggs whatever else you have
left
for me the secret of a good frittata is
in the sausage nice hot pan onions in
this on the onions Heat
nice and high
season
fennel seeds to give the onions
a really nice flavor everyone's used to
cooking sausages whole
but it's a really nice way of using them
to take them out of their thin skin
what we're going to do is crumple all
that wonderful spicy fennel sausage into
the onions it's going to release all
that flavor a lot quicker
pretty important to keep that gas nice
and high and the longer you caramelize
the sausage the more flavor
you're gonna gain
six whole eggs give your eggs a really
good mix
flat leaf parsley a staple in Italian
cooking chop it
quite rough
some Parmesan
it gives a really nice seasoning fresh
pepper
a little touch of salt
and then get it in there
bun your fork through it so when you
slice it
no one's complaining they've got less
sausage
I'm gonna make it even more Italian by
topping it with some Buffalo mozzarella
dry it and then slice it nice and thinly
twist it
mozzarella in
and then finally finish it with that
pounds and cheese get the top just as
tasty as it is the bottom
it needs three and a half to four
minutes under a red Hot Grill to achieve
the best results always ensure your oven
or grill are preheated to the perfect
temperature this is the thing I love
about Italian cooking it's about sharing
but always focusing on the ingredients
look at that
I mean it's incredible a little shake
the pan to make sure it comes out and
then spatula underneath and just leave
it
it's light
fluffy and it smells incredible and that
for me is a dream come true it's amazing
how far you can take six eggs and two
sausages
wow
spicy fennel sausage frittata My
ultimate Italian breakfast it's a
cracking start to the day
[Music]
Italian food puts a premium on fantastic
ingredients cooked simply
here's a bit of help on what to look for
when you're buying some of the key
ingredients for today's lunch and dinner
for dinner tonight I'll be cooking value
for money beef cheek
this large meaty muscle can cost as
little as two pound of Pop from your
local butcher but the rewards of cooking
it with a little love and Patience are
Bountiful
slash fried the meat from this
hard-working muscle is very tough but
slow braising will transform into four
Falls of melt in your mouth
deliciousness
I'll be using this cheeky cut for a
deliciously cheap Italian dinner that
will feed a whole family
[Music]
burrata one of Italy's most recent
cheesy exports was invented back in the
1920s from a need to make use of the
little scraps of mozzarella left in the
cheese making that
shreds are mixed with cream and encased
in a hand spun mozzarella pouch
this luxurious rich pugal and delicacy
is now becoming more popular in our
supermarkets
[Music]
if I had to choose one herb synonymous
with Italy this would be it basil the
perfect partner for tomato based dishes
or pounded with Parmesan and pine nuts
for a delicious pesto
Basil's soft silky aromatic leaves will
bring a taste of the Mediterranean to
any dish they touch and I'll be using it
in my ultimate Italian lunch
in much of Italy lunch is traditionally
seen as the most important meal of the
day and for a food assassination that's
really saying something whenever or
whatever Italians cook they always put a
premium on straightforward fresh food
prepared simply that's why Italian food
is so brilliant for the home cook for my
ultimate Italian lunch I'm cooking
scrummy sardines topped with a fragrant
gremolata dressing but first a
deliciously fresh orzo pasta salad this
is one of the Hidden Delicacies of
Italian pasta also because 90 of the
time it's always hidden in a soup or a
brothel minestrone and it looks like
large grains of rice but once they
absorb that water they double in size
It's a pasta that needs a lot of help
season it nicely pinch of salt a splash
of extra virgin olive oil fresh bay leaf
into the boiling water and that bay leaf
really helps to flavor the pasta give
you a little pan
turn left and right that stops any pasta
sticking to the bottom and the secret
behind cooking any pasta is having a
nice gentle rolling boil you just have
the gas up where the outside of the pan
is just rolling and all that also is
tumbling over each other gently boiling
past the rapidly tends to destroy the
outside texture it doesn't take the
marinade or the vinaigrette or the sauce
for the dressing parmesan Twist of fresh
pepper the zest of the lemon I'll
squeeze your lemon in there through your
fingers to catch all those seeds bring
that together with some extra virgin
olive oil
foreign s taste delicious toasting them
just elevates them
after eight minutes my orzo is perfectly
al dente
train it a little bit of cold water
through it slows the cooking process
down but stops it from going mushy it's
the size of pumpkin seeds now a drizzle
of olive oil and into the vinaigrette
whilst it's still warm just above room
temperature because the wall with a
pasta the more it absorbs the
vinaigrette and now some texture rocket
not finely chopped
on the fresh basil as well
roll them up like a big fat cigar slice
in half
and then chop the basil
crunch just sprinkle the toasty pine
nuts
it looks like a plate of jewels glistens
it's delicious very fragrant also pasta
salad now for sardines incredibly
healthy an absolutely delicious grilled
never ever be intimidated on looking for
fresh fish it's about the condition of
the fish Bright Eyes fresh gills nice
bright red interior and the firmness of
the flesh almost you could stand the
fish up on its own it needs to be that
fresh the best way to get flavor into
sardine is to grill it light seasoning
olive oil
and just roll the seasoning around
get your Rosemary peel off a few of the
little shards at the end so it's a
little bit sharp push the Rosemary in
almost like you're threading makes them
so much more flavoursome
that would be scared of those fine
little bones I remember growing up with
sardines tin sardines you didn't turn
your nose up at the bone once The
Griddle pan starts to smoke lightly
drizzle and then sardines on
two and a half to three minutes each
side
now for the grandma Lata a pretty great
that sits beautifully well on the
sardines freshly fastly just run the
knife once nothing worse when you over
chop parsley and all that delicious
flavors left on the board with zest and
juice of an orange and a lemon
you'll turn them now
that's about fragrance natural flavors
brilliant for grilled Meats as well
little touch of salt
and pepper
and then olive oil just to bring it
together
the garlic I almost want to be like a
secret weapon in there
grate it
bring that together you've got a very
fresh clean gremolata almost if we sat
on the Amalfi Coast
oh
then whilst the sardines are still nice
and warm and just thinly coat gremolata
I'd like to pass in the garlic to sit on
top and that's citrus from the lemon and
the orange to sort of dive underneath
see why Italian cuisine rides on the
freshest and the simplest execution they
allow their ingredients to become the
hero
not the chef
also salad with stunning grilled
sardines
[Music]
wherever you eat this dish it will fill
your senses with the sun and the Sea of
the Mediterranean delicious
[Music]
one of the things I really admire about
the Italian approach to food is not just
how they cook but how they eat and enjoy
food too it's very very relaxed and it's
all about sharing great food with
friends and family our home life is
pretty hectic so when we're all at home
together we try and have a bit of
Italian Spirit at meal time cheers right
my ultimate Italian dinner
this is one of the kids favorites
and I've got Jack helping me in the
kitchen wow
[Music]
we're hoping to wow the family with an
amazing quick fig Jam crostini with
creamy burrata and the hearty Mane a big
cheat Ragu with Papa Deli beef cheeks
just think the size of your little
cheeks yeah imagine the size of a cow
with them and the cheek is right
underneath here yeah
always give them a really nice season
with salt and pepper on there please so
bee cheeks very cheap they cut that
takes sort of a long time to cook yeah
but give it a bit of love let it cook in
the oven it comes out like a dream a
little touch
of oil in the pan what we want to do is
get them really nicely colored shed see
it into the pan oh cool layaway
get what that is
um
[Music]
sitting at the dock of the
beach beach
and then I want the onion chunky because
I'm gonna cook it for like
three three and a half hours so you go
down
down
and then again there and there so it
doesn't overcook
so a really good color on the cheeks
like that so how do you cook these at a
restaurants if they take so long they go
in the oven literally half past six
seven o'clock in the morning three and a
half four hours we're ready for lunch
and the longer you leave them in their
juices yeah and the cooking liquor the
better three guys close the garlic good
onions in and garlic in please nice
where's your Bailey there it is
get those onions and that garlic really
nicely colored
put the cheeks back in place right red
wine in cool okay the red wine is going
to deglaze the pan so deglaze will
basically sort of rinse all that flavor
off the bottom of the pan yeah okay
because that's going to make the most
amazing sauce
now you could use tomato puree but
chopped canned tomatoes you'll make a
much better sauce I'm gonna top that
with some stock so the secret of
braising is having little of the meat
exposed and 90 of it submerged see them
now yeah
they're like little crocodile heads
popping up out the water turn the gas
off and leave the lid just off at the
end there if we had to cover it
completely the steam hits the top yeah
the lid and all that water comes running
back it's solar still that's right in
the oven
140 150 for about three and a half to
four hours good job
Boom for pudding I'm making one of my
absolute favorite Italian desserts Banna
cotta with that quintessentially Italian
flavoring espresso
start by immersing two leaves of gelatin
in cold water and leave to soak
into a small saucepan add caster sugar
cream milk
sugar and a shot of good strong coffee
gently bring to a simmer and remove from
the hob
[Music]
wheeze out the soaked gelatin leaves and
stir into the hot cream until completely
dissolved
pour your cream mixture into a jug and
fill your molds just short of the rim
rinsing your molds in cold water before
filling will make it easier to get your
panna cotta out once it's set
[Music]
leaving the fridge for at least two to
three hours or overnight
[Music]
to make your cinnamon hazelnut brittle
pour caster sugar into a pan and cook
over medium Heat
until the sugar melts to a deep golden
brown
[Music]
scatter toasted hazelnuts into the
caramel
dust with ground cinnamon and leave to
set at room temperature
when your panna cotta is firm given each
mold a quick dip into boiling water
should ensure a perfect stress-free exit
onto the plate
foreign
[Music]
crunchy hazelnut brittle nothing could
be so deliciously elegant
right Captain Jack quick run through
Panna cottas are nearly set beef cheeks
I need it cooked we're gonna now do the
Fig and brighter crostini oh okay let's
take the figs we're gonna make a nice
slightly spicy fig Jam take off the tops
yep in half and each half into three
sugar the touch of salt in there okay
we're making a jam but we don't want a
bit too sweet and then these little
babies
what are they
ah what's the shape stars star
underneath taken from the fantasy plant
yeah and when you dry them like that so
intensifies the flavor really important
to count how many put in there okay yeah
so one two three four five so they're
just there from flavors and take them
out that's right secret here let's get
that camera going so when I hear about
Jam I don't think of caramel no but this
is a very fast champ caramel's starting
to color
I want you very carefully to drop the
figs in there good
so the juice out of the figs
is starting to break down the camera
you know what that is a little sweet
vanilla I love that on my challenge I've
got that sort of sweet and sour flavor
leave that cooking for three four
minutes
now let's slice our chapata in Italian
crostini means little bits of toast but
it can be made out of leftover baguette
sourdough or any crusty open textured
bread we're staying authentically
Italian with ciabatta
season them and then drizzle a little
touch of olive oil on there both sides
really important because we're going to
grill the bread push it down
put some lovely very lovely take it off
with a chapata toasted we need to
carefully extract the star anise pods
from our piping hot fig Jam
my Jack we've got one little bugger to
five oh no
is it there yes it is right now we've
got the green light to crush
[Music]
skins disintegrated in that caramel that
looks so nice
oh Jack carefully spreads the crostini
with our hot fig Jam I can unveil the
last element to our starter the creamy
Italian specialty borata
I'm not money bags
can be delicious this looks fun doesn't
it
we need to season them lightly drizzle
over a little olive oil and dust them
with lemon zest can you imagine that sat
there and you tear some of that off and
you stick it on top of that and
back to the main course to match our
hearty beef cheeks I've chosen to use
Papa Deli rule number one when cooking
pasta
salt in first salt and first good olive
oil in
pasta in
twist it round so you don't break it no
bring that back up the ball I was going
to take that through for four minutes
flat leaf parsley scrunch it up for me
yep and chop him now wait to see these
beef cheeks beauties
look at them
they're very soft I'm going to taste
um
it's so good
yeah you just dribbled on your jumper
really
right drain the pasta
salt pepper
pasta
little drizzle
of olive oil
I'm going to put your fresh pasta nicely
chopped nicely chopped
in
this is the magic bit okay you take a
little Ladle of the juice
put that at the bottom
cook
the pasta
on top of that sauce
honestly oh my gosh your sisters are
gonna love you even more now you know
what about when you cook this for your
girlfriend one day uh just tell you
where you got the recipe from William
promise promise I don't want you
stealing Daddy's Thunder
one
beautiful jaw on there two beautiful
Jaws on there
and then the third job and then you go
over
the sauce
how cool is that delicious you've got
the borrasa
and I've got the cheeks
let's go
[Music]
don't be cheeky get it
my ultimate Italian dinner
quick fig Jam crostini with creamy
borata a main course of slow cooked beef
cheek Ragu with Papa Deli and for
pudding espresso panna cotta with
cinnamon hazelnut brittle
a stunning meal to bring the whole
family together in the best Italian
tradition
Tilly
[Music]
um
how creamy is that that's more cheap
check please oh yes please of course you
can
Maggie how is it
so what's your favorite part I I really
like the cheeks
[Music]
not funny is when somebody grabs the
other cheek start worrying well the
right one
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck